NOW BACK TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
♪
>> Tucker: ALL THIS WEEK
WE'VE TAKEN TO YOU CITIES
ALONG THE WEST COAST TO
INVESTIGATE HOMELESSNESS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
FROM THE BEGINNING, WE
PLANNED TO SHOW HOW MUCH THE
PROBLEM HAS GROWN BUT EVEN
WE WERE SHOCKED BY THE SCALE
OF THE EPIDEMIC AND THE
PLACES WE VISITED.
THE HOMELESS ARE NOT JUST A
PROBLEM IN RICH ECONOMIC
HUBS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO BUT
DYING POST INDUSTRIAL CITIES
IN COLLEGE TOWNS AND EVEN
RURAL AREAS.
THE INVESTIGATION WAS A
LITTLE BIT STRONGER THAN WE
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE.
AND THE REACTION HAS BEEN
MUCH MORE PROFOUND THAN WE
ANTICIPATED, TOO.
IN SACRAMENTO, POLICE
PERFORMED A WARRANT SWEEP AT
THE CITY'S RIVER FRONT
ENCAMPMENT THE DAY AFTER OUR
PACKAGE AIRED.
30 PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED.
MOST OF THE ENCAMPMENTS
REMAIN AND THREATENING THE
STRUCTURAL INTEGRITY OF THE
CITY'S LIVE SYSTEM.
IN SEATTLE WE REPORTED THE
SHOCKING DRUG PROBLEMS
ENCAMPMENT OFF OF INTERSTATE
5.
POLICE RAIDED AND HUGE
QUANTITIES OF CRACKS,
HEROIN, METHAMPHETAMINE,
MARIJUANA AND THAT CHETYS
AND FIREARMS.
THEY EVEN TOOK A TOWARD.
THEY PLAN TO EVICT THE
RESIDENTS AND CLEAR THAT
CAMP NEXT WEEK.
SMALL CAMPS ARE LIKE UNEQUAL
TO THE PROBLEM WHICH AGAIN
IS GROWING.
THE FACT IS HOMELESSNESS IS
AMERICA'S FORGOTTEN CRISIS.
BELTWAY JOURNALISTS SPEND
THEIR DAYS IN TWITTER
COMPETITIONS TRYING TO PROVE
THEY ARE THE BEST AT HATING
TRUMP OR OPPOSING RUSSIA.
CAREER BUREAUCRATS OBSESSED
OVER TOPPLING GOVERNMENTS IN
IRAN OR VENEZUELA.
THEY REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE PROBLEMS STEADILY
ERODING THE COUNTRY WE
ACTUALLY LIVE.
IN AMERICA'S HOMELESS
POPULATION IS HUGE AND
GROWING ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNMENT EVEN AS THE
HOMELESS POPULATION RISES
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
SHELTERS IS DROPPING.
THAT MEANS MORE PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS, MORE GARBAGE.
MORE NEEDLES, MORE HUMAN
WASTE.
MORE HUMAN MISERY.
OF COURSE, WE COULD BUILD
MORE SHELTERS AND PROVIDE
FOR TREATMENT FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS AND ADDICTION.
WE COULD CLEAN UP PARKS AND
SIDEWALKS AND RIVER BANKS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE SHOWN
THEMSELVES BIZARRELY UNWILL
TO DO ANY OF THAT.
THOSE STRATEGIES WOULD HELP
BUT THEY DON'T CONFRONT THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM.
WHY ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WINDING UP LIVING OUTSIDE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
WOULD REQUIRE INVESTIGATING
AND FIXING FAR DEEPER
AILMENTS OPIOIDS MUST BE
TREATED LIKE WHAT THEY'RE.
THEY THE SINGLE GREATEST
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO FACE
AMERICA SINCE THE SPANISH
FLEW A CENTURY AGO.
WE NEED TO FIND A REAL WAY
TO LOWER HOUSING PRICES AND
FIND A PATH FOR WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE TO OWN HOMES
INSTEAD OF SELLING THE
COUNTRY TO CHINESE INVESTORS
AND PRIORITIZING RETURNS OF
REAL ESTATE WHICH IS WHAT WE
NOW DO.
WE NEED TO HONESTLY ADDRESS
THE COLLAPSE OF FAMILIES.
IMPLEMENT FAMILIES THAT KEEP
THEM TOGETHER OR AT LEAST
TRY.
WE NEED TO STOP VIEWING
STRUGGLING AMERICANS AS
DEFECTIVE PEOPLE THAT
DESERVE TO BE REPLACED BY
SUPERIOR FOREIGN IMMIGRANTS
THE PELOSI MODEL.
BUT, PERHAPS MOST OF ALL WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE WAY
MADERNITY IS DESTROYING
PEOPLE.
MODERN CAREERS AND CULTURE
ARE MAKING PEOPLE DEPRESSED,
ADDICTED INSECURE.
IN SOME CASES, MANY CASES
MAKING THEM INSANE.
FOR THESE PROBLEMS THE
HOMELESS ARE JUST THE MOST
VISIBLE REFLECTION OF MUCH
GREATER SOCIETAL EMERGENCY.
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS ARE
EASY TO SOLVE.
OTHERS ARE NOT.
BUT HOMELESSNESS IS AN
AMERICAN CRISIS AND IT'S
GETTING WORSE.
WE PROMISE TO CONTINUE
COVERING IT AS LONG AS IT
TAKES FOR THINGS TO GET
BETTER.
BECAUSE A COUNTRY AS NOBLE
AND PROSPEROUS AS OURS